[Musica]
signori e signori buonasera e benvenuti
a bordo di questa astronave che oggi
partendo dalle orbite silenziose
indisturbate matematiche imperturbabili
ai confini del sistema solare ci porterà
qui in questo teatro in un viaggio
attraverso il cosmo alla ricerca del suo
contrario speculare il caos e in questo
viaggio incontreremo molti oggetti
costruiti dall'uomo una volta la punta
di diamante dell'ingegneria aerospaziale
oggi ridotti a degli ammassi di detriti
dei relitti che galleggiano in questo
oceano gravitazionale e come in ogni
voce ano e si rispetti
cominciamo subito a trovare un messaggio
dentro una bottiglia una bottiglia che
adesso apparirà alle mie spalle dove
sono disegnati un uomo una donna le
istruzioni per ascoltare questo
particolare disco è anche l'indirizzo
del mittente contiene delle immagini
della terra dei messaggi di pace sono
stati scelti oltre 50 anni fa da un
grande scienziato carla saganne come
biglietto da visita della nostra umanità
nel caso queste speciali bottiglie
andassero ad allenarsi sulle spiagge di
qualche pianeta e qualche civiltà
extraterrestre fosse curiosa di
conoscerci di queste bottiglie ce ne
sono quattro e si trovano a bordo di
quattro astronavi sono il pioneer 10
pioneer 11 poi ager 1 e 2 sono gli
oggetti che si trovano oggi costruiti
dall'uomo più lontani dal pianeta terra
siamo oggi qui a 17 miliardi di
chilometri da questo teatro ma
mettiamoci subito in viaggio per andare
un po più verso la nostra stella e
immediatamente partiamo eccola la nostra
stella e ci portiamo a 600 milioni di
chilometri da qui
arriviamo nella regione dei cosiddetti
giganti gassosi giove e saturno e qui
incontriamo solamente due oggetti
anzi da qualche settimana solamente uno
è rimasto è questo che avete appena
visto passare alle spalle si tratta
della sonda juno della nasa l'altra
cassini dopo dieci anni di onorato
servizio ha deciso di sprofondare
attraverso le nuvole di saturno e ha
lasciato dietro di sé soltanto un
piccolo robot abbandonato sulle spiagge
di metano di una delle sue lune andiamo
avanti non ci sono grossi pericoli qua e
ci portiamo beh questo è il pianeta
rosso marte il pianeta più osservato
dopo la terra qui incontriamo moltissimi
oggetti costruiti dall'uomo e inviati a
esplorare questo pianeta e questi
moltissimi oggetti dopo tanti anni
cominciano a perdere un po di pezzettini
un po di detriti debri è il termine
tecnico in inglese
ecco per adesso non ce ne preoccupiamo
troppo ma nell'arco degli anni
causeranno sicuramente dei problemi alle
missioni che seguiranno dunque bisogna
prestare attenzione
continuiamo rapidamente questo viaggio e
ci portiamo adesso a un milione e mezzo
circa di chilometri da terra sono dei
punti un po speciali si chiamano i punti
lagrangiani ce ne sono cinque sono dei
punti dove vige un perfetto equilibrio
tra la gravità della terra la luna e il
sole un oggetto posto in questi punti
come vedete qui può osservare
tranquillamente il sole ad esempio il
caso di questo telescopio si chiama
herschel e restando indisturbato
immobile e alla fine della sua vita
operativa basta una spintarella
accendendo i motori e lui se ne va
indisturbato a parcheggiare e intorno al
sole lasciando libera la postazione per
i satelliti che verranno dopo
dunque ancora nessuno problema
continuiamo e questa volta invece
andiamo ad incontrare le prime orbite
terrestri di questo lungo viaggio sono
le orbite altamente ellittiche delle
orbite molto speciali che hanno degli
apogee lontanissimi dalla terra ma i
satelliti che le popolano sono lì per
fornire dei servizi alle zone più
impervie del nostro pianeta i ghiacci i
poli in particolare servono le tundre la
siberia
i ghiacciai l'antartide nel fare questo
sfrecciano poi quasi a sfiorare la
superficie della terra in termini
ovviamente sempre relativi parliamo di
qualche centinaio di chilometri
e dunque se ci mettiamo a cavalcioni di
uno di questi satelliti ci portiamo
adesso in una delle regioni più
densamente popolate nel nostro sistema
solare si chiama l'orbita geostazionaria
ed è posta 36.000 chilometri da questo
teatro sull'equatore si tratta di una
regione e che deve il suo nome al fatto
una particolare proprietà un satellite
posto in questa regione e impiega
esattamente un giorno un giorno siderale
cosiddetto per fare una rotazione
intorno alla terra e dunque agli occhi
di un osservatore sulla terra
questo oggetto apparirà immobile capito
immediatamente che è una situazione
molto peculiare ed interesse per
chiunque per esempio voglia disporre un
ripetitore un ripetitore per emissioni
televisive o telefoniche o radiofoniche
oppure che voglia disporre un satellite
per l'osservazione meteorologica per
vedere i fronti e delle nuvole come
avanzano e dunque questo fa sì che i 500
i più satelliti operativi che sono
disposti in questa particolare regione
in realtà non siano equamente
distribuiti ma si trovino laddove c'è
più business
dunque per esempio sopra l'europa oppure
sulle americhe o sullo scenario antico
tra le due
questo fa sì che queste particolari
posizioni siano particolarmente
affollate e c'è da dire anche un'altra
cosa che in realtà a dispetto dell'orbe
il nome di stazionaria questi satelliti
non sono per nulla stazionarie anzi lo
sarebbero se la terra rispettasse le
astrazioni della fisica newtoniana
dunque se fosse una sfera perfetta ma
non è una sfera perfetta anzi ha una
forma piuttosto di pera con un equatore
che non è una circonferenza perfetta
bensì un ellisse molto schiacciata e
anche la distribuzione di massa è lungi
dall estero omogenea al contrario
abbiamo crosta terrestre
abbiamo degli oceani ecco tutto questo
ha aggiunto al fatto che nello spazio
c'è un vento detto solare fa sì che
questi oggetti questi satelliti siano in
continuo movimento
debbano lottare contro tutte queste
perturbazioni accendendo i loro motori
continuamente dunque consumando il
combustibile di bordo
questo è un elemento essenziale perché
questo combustibile non è infinito e una
volta terminato cosa succede succede che
questi satelliti restano in balia di
queste forze di questi eventi e dunque
come dei relitti se non vengono tolti da
questo orbita e spesso non vengono tolti
restano e dunque possono andare a
sbattere contro per così dire altri
satelliti creare delle collisioni avete
capito che questo è uno dei rischi più
importanti e se è vero a 36 mila
chilometri di quota
e ancora piu importante stiamo scendendo
rapidamente a circa 800 chilometri di
quota siamo nella regione qui in
assoluto la più popolata in questa
regione abbiamo i satelliti per
l'osservazione della terra sono dei
satelliti a volte anche per lo
spionaggio militare ce ne sono
all'incirca 800 che però condividono
questa regione con circa udite udite 155
milioni di piccoli frammenti di
dimensioni che vanno da 1 mm un
centimetro dunque praticamente
invisibili non solo all'occhio nudo dei
telescopi ma anche ai radar pressochè
questi oggetti sono microscopici dunque
voi direte che problema c'è il problema
è che viaggiano a una velocità di circa
7 chilometri ogni secondo dunque sono
dei proiettili carichi di energia
cinetica che nel momento quando entrano
in collisione con un altro satellite
ovviamente provocano delle esplosioni e
non uso il termine esplosione come una
bomba in modo casuale ma in realtà è
quello che è successo è successo molto
spesso per esempio negli anni 70
le due superpotenze stati uniti e unione
sovietica hanno effettuato delle
dimostrazioni di forza dimostrato di
essere in grado di colpire dei satelliti
lanciando dei missili da tener lago
d'aria o degli incrociatori questi
eventi hanno ovviamente
causato molto caos nello spazio hanno
causato molti detriti e questa volta non
naturalmente prodotti dalla
disgregazione causata dalle radiazioni
oppure dai cicli termici ai quali il
satellite soggetto bensì sono stati
veramente voluti dall uomo dunque
causati da esplosioni e fino al momento
in cui queste cose sono avvenute ad
altezze relativamente basse
il problema è stato risolto la tua madre
natura diciamo che attraverso
l'attrazione gravitazionale ha fatto
rientrare questi piccoli frammenti in
tempi molto rapidi
non è stato questo invece il la
situazione che si è generata il 7
gennaio dell'anno 2011 quando la stessa
dimostrazione di potenza l'ha voluta
effettuare anche la nuova superpotenza
arrivata la cina in questo caso la cina
ha dimostrato di essere capace di
colpire un suo vecchio satellite ha una
quota di ben 800 chilometri dunque
proprio nella regione che abbiamo visto
prima la più densamente popolata e gli
effetti di questa esplosione sono ancora
visibili oggi e lo saranno ancora per
migliaia di anni
perché questi detriti resteranno e
restano come adesso vedremo nella
prossima nel prossimo filmato che sta
per partire come una nuvola una luna che
continua a viaggiare espandendosi
cambiando forma e diventa sempre più
difficile ed anche da prevedere la
posizione questa questo fenomeno ha già
mietuto con qualche vittima
in particolare un satellite russo
qualche anno fa è stato letteralmente
tagliata in due dal passaggio attraverso
questa nuvola e questi eventi hanno in
effetti dimostrato che il re è nudo che
in realtà tutti questi trattati
internazionali che vietano il
dispiegamento di armi di distruzione di
massa intorno al nostro pianeta
in realtà questi tutti questi trattati
valgono valgono molto poco in quanto
spesso si urtano alla volontà delle
superpotenze o anche degli attori
commerciali certe volte di continuare a
esercitare il loro potere
tant'è vero che per esempio non riescono
a impedire l'attraversamento dello
spazio da parte dei missili balistici
intercontinentali e tanto meno dei
missili anti missili tutto questo perché
queste armi non entrano in orbita
intorno alla terra dunque non vengono
non ricadono dicevamo nel mandato dei
trattati internazionali di cui sopra e
queste armi o guerre stellari non sono
affatto uniche nel loro genere anzi
ultimamente diciamo sono state anche
sperimentati dei laser molto potenti che
riescono ad accecare le ottiche
estremamente delicati di questi
satelliti sono stati anche testati dei
satelliti con tecnologia stealth
ovverosia che li rendono praticamente
invisibili ai radar da terra e capaci
dunque di avvicinarsi ad altri satelliti
per ad esempio ascoltare nelle
telecomunicazioni o interferire o
addirittura ma non è per lì
meccanicamente sempre se il satellite
obiettivo non ha a sua volta dispiegato
intorno a sé dei microsatelliti detti
angeli custodi che assicurano una sorta
di sorveglianza di prossimità impedendo
dunque altre manomissioni avete capito
che tutto questo fa causando
un'impennata vertiginosa del numero di
libri dunque di frammenti che adesso e
popolano la nostra nostra atmosfera
tutto questo è chiaro che i nostri le
nostre agenzie devono prendere atto di
queste di questi fenomeni e stanno
portando stanno sviluppando nuovi
sistemi per pulire l'orbita dunque si
parla ad esempio di rimorchiatori capaci
di agganciarsi a altri satelliti per
imprimere una spinta per farli rientrare
nella terra verso la terra dove
bruceranno
gli strati alti dell'atmosfera in ogni
caso quello che conta è ricordarsi in
questo momento che noi stiamo vivendo
una nuova corsa allo spazio una nuova
corsa allo spazio che non è di tipo
solamente di tipo strategico militare ma
è anche e soprattutto una competizione a
capitalizzare al meglio gli investimenti
nella ricerca e nello sviluppo spaziale
al fine di generare crescita economica
di generare impiego occupazione
innovazione trasformare questi
investimenti in una nuova generazione di
imprenditori ma tutti i satelliti di cui
abbiamo parlato oggi in realtà sono
essenziali per le attività economiche
della nostra vita quotidiana e ci
aiutano nelle trasmissioni ci aiutano
nelle telecomunicazioni ci aiutano a
gestire crisi sicurezza stiamo in
qualche modo espandendo la sfera delle
attività economiche e sociali terrestri
fine confini del sistema solare
ma questa se vogliamo mantenere che essa
crescita e far sì che questa crescita
sia sostenibile nel tempo
dobbiamo affrontare il caos che è
generato da questa crescita è che
abbiamo visto oggi in queste immagini e
per farlo dobbiamo prenderne coscienza
rapidamente e anche agire al fine in
qualche modo di evitare che questo caos
divori questa preziosa essenziale
risorsa naturale che lo spazio intorno
al nostro pianeta
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]